IT'S UNCLEAR WHETHER MR. KUSHNER
WILL STILL BE ABLE TO DO THIS.
BRET.
>> Bret: THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THERE ARE GROWING QUESTIONS
TONIGHT ABOUT SOME OF THE
SPENDING PRACTICES AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND URBAN
DEVELOPING.
UNDER NEW SECRETARY BEN CARSON.
CORRESPONDENT PETER DOOCY LOOKS
OF THE ALLEGATIONS THAT WHILE
CUTS WERE BEING MADE IN SERVICES
FOR AMERICANS, MONEY WAS SPENT
FREELY ON FURNITURE AND DECOR.
>> YOU MIGHT THINK THE CABINET
MEMBER WHO SPENT 31,000 TAXPAYER
DOLLARS ON A DINING SET WOULD BE
THE SECRETARY OF INTERIOR
DECORATING.
BUT IT'S NOT.
THE NEW OWNER OF A DINING SET
THE COST IS MUCH AS AN AUDI,
HOUSING AND URBAN DEVELOPMENT
SECRETARY BEN CARSON.
THE DINING SET HEADED FOR HIS
PRIVATE DINING ROOM AT HUD COST
SIX TIMES MORE THAN THE BUDGET
FOR UPGRADES.
A HUD SPOKESMAN SAID "THANKS FOR
REACHING OUT.
I WILL GET YOU SOMETHING."
THAT WAS AT 11:26.
NO WORD ON WHAT HAS CHANGED IN
SECRETARY CARSON'S THOUGHTS ON
>> ANYBODY HOTELS ME, LIKE
NANCY PELOSI, YOU CAN'T REDUCE
IT BY 1 PENNY.
IT WILL BE A COMPLETE DISASTER.
WE ARE 100% EFFICIENT.
>> CARSON ISN'T THE ONLY
OFFICIAL WHOSE EXPENDITURES HAVE
DRAWN SCRUTINY DURING TRUMP'S
TENURE.
FORMER HHS SECRETARY TOM PRICE
HAD TO RESIGN WHEN THE PRESIDENT
SOURED ON HIS USE OF PRIVATE
JETS.
EPA ADMINISTRATOR SCOTT PRUITT
NBA ADMINISTRATOR DAVID SHULKIN
HAVE HAD THEIR TRAVEL INVOICES
SCRUTINIZED.
ALL THIS DESPITE WORKING FOR A
COMMANDER IN CHIEF WHO SIGNED AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER LAST YEAR
DIRECTED AT ELIMINATING
WASHINGTON'S WASTE.
>> THIS ORDER REQUIRES A
THOROUGH EXAMINATION OF EVERY
EXECUTIVE DEPARTMENT AND AGENCY
TO SEE WHERE MONEY IS BEING
WASTED AND HOW SERVICES CAN BE
IMPROVED.
>> DEMOCRATS ARE PLEDGING TO
GIVE CARSON A THOROUGH EXAM.
>> WHAT'S APPROPRIATE IS AN
INVESTIGATION BY THE GOVERNMENT
ACCOUNTING OFFICE INTO WHETHER
THERE IS A VIOLATION OF WHAT'S
KNOWN AS THE ANTIDEFICIENCY ACT.
>> REPUBLICANS INVESTIGATING.
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE CHAIR TREY
GOWDY TOLD HUD TO PRESERVE ALL
DOCUMENTS ABOUT REDECORATING.
HE IS TRYING TO SEE IF THERE IS
MERIT TO A HUD EMPLOYEE'S CLAIM